Johnathan's like gold but to see how
many different ways he could piss me off
no no no no that's not true
people used to think we were twins
because no Jennifer had all these pieces
ready like things that would just annoy
her he thinks he's always supposed to
get in his way I'm just right we used to
also do this hand clapping thing that
was really
I was at school instead of going to
class two of my friends were like let's
go to morongo this Indian casino needs
my friend call the school as each
other's dad's and say that we weren't
gonna be in today so we go I go eight
bucks in my pocket and just dreams and I
come back I make eighty eight dollars
eleven times irony which is awesome so
my mom text me and asked if my brother
was at school and then my friends are
like oh he went in my wrong I was like
no mom he went to the casino where you
can't play because he's not 18 I was
saying your mom calls and you're like
it's a cool guys I got this and I'm like
I couldn't get him telling my mom like
oh yeah I'm at school what she already
knows of this land right here like I
might bail me out
devastation she did me wrong and I
wasn't gonna let it go by it was a lot
of me giving Sara the silent treatment
this was like our longest fight at first
I'm like I don't care like whatever but
he would try to rub it in my face
finally my mom knew that I was the
better child that I am the good girl
that God has given them and he is you
know what he is really high school I was
sitting on my bed I had our dog Cindy
she's you know you cute little dog and
my sister barges into my room and she's
like I want the dog like in my room and
I'm like no it's my turn to have the dog
I'm studying already I grab the dog my
sister like goes to punch me I put up my
left hand jump some nails my pinky and I
knew right away it was brilliant it was
really like I was pretty she packs a
punch
she acted like it was fire he calls my
dad and he goes fever the next day I
went to a party so I go into my sister's
room
see all these wrestlers to obsessive
tours and stuff I like toppled on great
kids no I didn't like them I emptied the
contents like all over her room and I
came back and all my stuff was lying on
the floor and one of the things he put
into the room was a vacuum pull out of
anger I grabbed the vacuum and I went to
attack my brother with it ball swing the
shoulder doesn't really have a good
swing so
I mean it's no worse than the time she
grown to be a person doesn't hold
grudges very like I don't really hold
them anymore anymore yeah I you word
anymore well you know we don't get in
any fights
I think it's normal for brothers and
sisters to fight when you're going up
because you got to see the good in the
bad and each other to really know
somebody if you don't fight you're lying
to yourself 14 we should call my parents
and tell them this movie shot things
today that we still fight about owes me
money